[Music]
hi everyone I'm Steve Brenton from the
University of Washington and I'm really
excited about a new lecture series on
the singular value decomposition or the
SVD this is chapter one of our new
textbook on data driven science and
engineering by myself and Nathan Koontz
and I'm gonna walk you through this
extremely useful tool the SVD in about
twenty short lectures telling you all
about how you can use it for data
reduction dimensionality reduction and
as a foundation of machine learning okay
so the SVD is one of the most well used
and really just general-purpose useful
tools in numerical linear algebra for
data processing so I always think of
this as a data reduction tool where you
have high dimensional data maybe you
have megapixel images or you have a
video with very very high resolution you
have this big data and the SVD is gonna
help us reduce this data into the key
features that are that are necessary for
analyzing understanding and describing
this data so the SVD is really one of
the first steps in most dimensionality
reduction or many dimensionality
reduction and machine learning
techniques so more specifically than the
data reduction I think of the SVD as a
data-driven generalization of the
Fourier transform so data-driven
generalization of the Fourier transform
and I'm just gonna say the FFT so the
FFT is one of the most useful
transformations and all of mathematics
based on sine and cosine expansions to
approximate functions
there's also Bessel's functions Airy's
functions spherical harmonics and this
is this was the technique of the the
last generation of computational science
and engineering was to use these
mathematical modes these mathematical
transformations to map a system of
interest into some new coordinate system
where would become simple but in many
systems of interest today
like let's say I have a turbulent flow
over a Boeing wing there isn't an easy
off-the-shelf mathematical
transformation or set of basis modes
that describes that behavior and so what
the SVD the singular value decomposition
is going to allow us to do is to tailor
a coordinate system or a transformation
based on the data that we have so I
think of these as tailored to the
specific problem okay so they have a lot
of features in common with the Fourier
transform as we're gonna learn
throughout this video sequence but it's
tailored to the specific problem that
you're interested in to the specific
data that you have access to okay so I'm
not gonna in the next lecture I'm gonna
go through actually defining a data
matrix how you compute the SVD and what
it means here I just want to tell you
kind of how you can use it so one thing
you can do is you can use it to solve
matrix system of equations ax equals to
B so linear systems of equations for non
square ei matrices and we're going to
use this in particular for linear
regression models and for many other
things so if I have data let's say
health data for a bunch of patients and
I want to build a model of how different
risk factors map to some disease I can
build the best fit model x given data a
and B using least squares linear
regression again built on the the
singular value decomposition I can also
use this as the basis for the principal
component analysis PCA which is one of
the most widely used techniques in all
of statistics for taking high
dimensional data and trying to
understand it in terms of its dominant
patterns or correlations so that's a
keyword we're going to talk a lot about
is correlation the singular value
decomposition is going to take high
dimensional data and distill it down
into the key features the key
correlations in that data that you can
then use to interpret and understand and
model that data
it really is used everywhere it's used
in Facebook Google Microsoft so for
example it's used in the Google page
rank algorithm so when you search
something on Google and it presents the
websites in an order it's using an SVD
for that a singular value decomposition
it's the basis of many many facial
recognition algorithms to tell who which
person is who from an image so you could
again build these singular value
decomposition representations of human
faces it's also used in recommender
systems like Amazon and Netflix where it
will essentially build correlation
patterns of what types of people like
what types of movies and this is just a
very very very brief list of all of the
examples of the SVD in industry so I
always like to tell my students that the
SVD is one of the most important
algorithms if you want to actually use
linear algebra to make money okay so
very very useful part of the reason it's
so widely adopted is because it's based
on very very simple linear algebra
simple and interpretable linear algebra
which means that you can use it really
on any anytime you have a data matrix
you can compute the SVD and you can get
interpretable understandable features
that you can then build models on it's
scalable you can apply it to very large
data sets and so that's that's also nice
is that you know Google's
it has massive massive data sets they
can still run these scalable singular
value decomposition on their data so I'm
extremely excited about walking you
through kind of all of the uses of the
SVD we're going to talk about principal
components analysis correlation matrices
least squares regression I ghen faces
for facial recognition and a whole host
of other things so I hope you find this
extremely useful again it's chapter 1 of
our book data-driven science and
engineering all of the code is online so
we'll also code up a lot of these
examples in MATLAB and Python ok thank
you